[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages
heute mit christian sievers guten abend
in allen an diesem letzten septembertag
geben sie uns 20 minuten für den
nachrichtenüberblick mit dem sport
nachher in der sendung grund katja
stresow in gut 15 minuten journal und
das sind unsere wichtigsten themen
höchste anstieg seit fast 30 jahren
teure energie treibt in deutschland die
inflationsrate auf 4,1 prozent
nach dem chaos in wahllokalen müssen die
berliner in einigen stadtteilen noch mal
neu wählen
stark auch in der champions league
bayern münchen besiegt dynamo kiew klar
mit 5 0
aber erst das leben in deutschland wird
teurer und alle spüren es besonders
bitter für verbraucher und sparer deren
kaufkraft schwächelt und sparguthaben
verlieren an wert die inflation ist so
hoch wie seit 28 jahren nicht mehr
schauen wir uns das mal ein bisschen
genauer an seit jahresbeginn zieht die
inflation an und liegt jetzt bei 4,1
prozent so hoch war sie zuletzt
das ganze wird vor allem getrieben durch
hohe energiekosten die sind gestiegen um
14,3 prozent im vergleich zum letzten
jahr aber auch lebensmittel wurden
deutlich teurer
um fast 5% dominik müller rosell
berichtet
über 1000 liter diesel tankt ein lkw der
spedition stroms aus krefeld bei einem
tankstellenshop in letzter zeit geht das
richtig ins geld um 40 prozent sind die
dieselkosten innerhalb eines jahres
gestiegen von etwas über einem euro auf
nun rund 1 45 pro liter ein preisanstieg
den sie weitergeben müssen unsere kunden
müssen es letztendlich in ihren
preiskalkulationen dementsprechend
berücksichtigen und bei konsumgütern
landes nachher alte mit 213 zusätzlichen
kosten auch auf jedem joghurtbecher der
im supermarkt regal steht
vieles ist teurer geworden nicht nur
sprit auch obst und gemüse tomaten etwa
fast 20 prozent teurer als noch vor
einem monat ein spürbarer anstieg
am ende des monats hat man mehr für
lebensmittel ausgegeben wie für andere
dinge das alles einfach teuer geworden
und jetzt erschreckend finde das auch
dass die gaspreise so explodieren noch
können was bezahlen und ich weiß wie es
weitergeht corona hat handel und preise
durcheinandergewirbelt nach extrem
geringer nachfrage letztes jahr nun
normalisierung entsprechend steigen die
preise wieder und holen versäumtes nach
sagen experten wir erwarten dass im
november die inflation noch einmal
ansteigen wird so richtung 5 prozent
auch im dezember
danach wird sich das ganze aber wieder
normalisieren wir rechnen derzeit nicht
mit einem dauerhaften anstieg der
inflation und das ist glaube ich dass
wichtige auch für die bevölkerung ein
vorübergehendes phänomen also doch
gleichzeitig warnen experten müsse man
wachsam sein dass die preise nicht
langfristig außer kontrolle geraten
bringen wir valerie haller noch mit dazu
in frankfurt war region amt müsste die
europäische zentralbank nicht langsam
mal eingreifen nein muss sie nicht die
ezb geht davon aus dass das nur ein
vorübergehendes phänomen des videos auch
gerade im bericht gehört haben also eine
folge der pandemie und dass sich die
inflation stark beruhigen dürfte
kommendes jahr deswegen haben sich die
währungshüter auch gerade erst mehr
flexibilität verschafft sie haben
festgelegt dass sie nicht mehr sofort an
der zinsschraube drehen müssen wenn die
inflation über oder unter zwei prozent
liegt also künftig darf es eine zeit
lang ruhig auch mal ein bisschen mehr
inflation seien ja das spielt natürlich
all den ländern in der eurozone in die
hände die hoch verschuldet sind
ultraniedrige zinsen heißt ja nichts
anderes als schulden machen bleibt
günstig das geht natürlich auf kosten
von rentnern sparen und beschäftigten
deren geld deutlich an kaufkraft
verliert unter ökonomen jedenfalls
wachsen mittlerweile auch schon die
zweifel dass die preise demnächst
wirklich wieder fallen schon möglich
dass wir jedoch mit einer höheren
inflation noch eine ganze weile rechnen
müssen valerie hat sich dank für diese
erläuterungen so und jetzt in der
sendung die frage wer wird dieses land
künftig regieren alle infrage kommenden
parteien haben jetzt ihre
verhandlungsteams für die
sondierungsgespräche benannt und auch
die termine für die weiteren treffen
stehen fest die union will ab sonntag
mitmischen da sind die gespräche mit der
fdp am dienstag dann mit den grünen
andreas ruppert wer spricht wann und mit
wem und was für eine regierungskoalition
kommt am ende dabei raus diese fragen
sind es die die politischen akteure in
der hauptstadt momentan umtreiben
cdu-parteizentrale in einer digitalen
sonder präsidiumssitzung fällt der
beschluss weiter auf sieg zu spielen
nach langer kontroverser diskussion wird
entschieden mit fdp und grünen über ein
unions geführtes jamaika bündnis zu
reden wir gehen natürlich auch mit einer
offenheit bezüglich der anderen
positionen in diese gespräche weil wir
brücken bauen wollen weil es wichtig ist
dass dieses land gut geführt wird und
nachhaltig in die zukunft geht die
grünen haben heute ihre fraktionsspitze
erst einmal kommissarisch im amt
bestätigt das gesprächsangebot der union
werden sie annehmen
wir haben sehr deutlich gemacht wir
sprechen mit allen gleichwohl ist es so
dass wir davon ausgehen dass die
übereinstimmung mit der spd größer sind
als mit anderen ob der auftrag des
wählers ist es alle seriösen demokraten
jetzt miteinander sprechen und dass man
wenn man diese gespräche geführt hat
dann eine entscheidung trifft am sonntag
spricht die spd erst mit der fdp dann
mit den grünen
sozialdemokraten setzen alles auf die
ampel koalition wir wollen schnell
darüber reden ob wir eine regierung
bilden können wir sind dazu bereit wir
glauben dass das sehr gut gelingen kann
den großen herausforderungen die vor uns
liegen und deswegen gibt es für uns
gerade keinen plan b und kein nachdenken
über alternativen
die politischen sondierungen nehmen
fahrt auf die zeitpläne stehen jetzt
muss inhaltlich ausgelotet werden wer
politisch mit wem am besten kann
eine wichtige entscheidung bei der afg
die bundestagsfraktion hat alice weidl
und tino copala zur neuen doppelspitze
gewählt nachdem die sitzung gestern
unterbrochen worden waren hat sich das
wahlkampf spitzenduo heute durchgesetzt
die fdp hatte bei der bundestagswahl nur
noch 10,3 prozent der zweitstimmen
erhalten und ist im neuen bundestag
nicht mehr die größte oppositionspartei
so vom bundestag jetzt in die berliner
landespolitik die wahlen dort am sonntag
waren kein besonderer ausweis für
reibungslose organisation das chaos in
manchen wahllokalen schlägt auch vier
tage danach noch hohe wellen manche
experten spekulieren sogar über eine
mögliche wiederholung von teilen der
wahl
die berliner hatten am sonntag die wahl
gleich auf mehreren ebenen bundestag
abgeordnetenhaus bezirksverordnete
volksentscheid und sie brauchten dafür
viel geduld es gab lange warteschlangen
weil stimmzettel fehlten oder vertauscht
waren nils schneider jetzt mit mir
als nadine hübner bei ihrem wahllokal
ankommt ist es kurz nach 17 uhr am
sonntag die stimmung vor ort gereizt und
zwar eine riesige schlange die leute
waren schon sauer die leute sind
gegangen
die leute waren frustriert wie keiner
wusste bescheid bis die wahlhelfer dann
meinten es gibt schon den ganzen tag
keine wahlzettel mehr als sie ihre
stimme endlich abgeben kann ist es 19
uhr 30 in charlottenburg wilmersdorf
wurden wohl stimmen zur
bezirksverordnetenversammlung nur
geschätzt in anderen stadtteilen lagen
falsche wahlzettel aus die so
abgegebenen stimmen sind alle ungültig
in tempelhof schöneberg wurde heute noch
einmal ausgezählt ergebnis alles glatt
gelaufen hier war man gut vorbereitet
also für mich entspreche mal für den
tempelhof schöneberg von wahlkreis
war es abzusehen dass es auf jeden fall
sehr viel länger dauern wird der druck
und sehr viel stärker sein wird auch der
andrang letztlich größer sein wird
allein mit den fünf wahlzettel
juristen halten aber eine neuwahl in
teilen der stadt nicht mehr für völlig
ausgeschlossen
neuwahlen sind nur dann gerechtfertigt
wenn sich die fehler bei der wahl auf
die zusammensetzung des bundestages oder
des abgeordnetenhauses von berlin
auswirken bei der bundestagswahl ist das
glaube ich nicht der fall das sind
relativ eindeutige ergebnisse bei der
berliner abgeordnetenhauswahl gibt sehr
knappe wahlergebnis
und da könnte das der fall sein auf zdf
nachfrage teilen alle zwölf berliner
bezirke mit dass sie die ergebnisse
derzeit überprüfen erst danach könne man
über mögliche neuwahlen entscheiden
der arbeitsmarkt in deutschland
entwickelt sich positiv die
bundesagentur für arbeit meldet im
september zwei millionen
465.000 arbeitslose das sind 114 1000
weniger als im vormonat die quote sinkt
auf 5,4 prozent im vergleich zum
september vergangenen jahres waren
382.000 menschen weniger ohne job
die impfzentren das war in den
dunkelsten phasen der korona pandemie
ein lichtblick aber einer um den es auch
einige diskussionen gab heute ist für
die meisten impfzentren der letzte tag
sie machen in vielen teilen des landes
dicht seit dezember wurden sie nach und
nach aus dem boden gestampft mehr als
die hälfte aller impfungen gab es hier
etwa 64 millionen dosen aber es gab auch
kritik beispielsweise an den
vergleichsweise sehr hohen kosten bei
einer aktuellen impfquote von 64,4
prozent geht jetzt eine ära zuende
elisabeth schmidt berichtet lea
barkewitz bekommt eine der letzten von
mehr als 800.000 spritzen die im
impfzentrum hannover messe verabreicht
wurden heute abend ist dann in allen
zentren in niedersachsen schluss ich
finde es schade weil es eine super
gelegenheit war einfach sich impfen zu
lassen weil die hausärzte neben ist
super schwierig ist nimmt termin zu
bekommen es ist ruhig geworden in den
impfzentren lange warteschlangen chaos
bei der terminvergabe impfstoffmangel
alles vorbei unverzichtbar waren die
zentren in den vergangenen monaten sagt
die gesundheitsministerin wir haben in
den letzten wochen 40.000 pro woche
geimpft das haben wir früher an einem
tag kämpft die großen zentren sind nicht
mehr klar state of the art in den
meisten bundesländern machen heute alle
impfzentren dicht in berlin bremen
hessen thüringen und bayern bleiben
vereinzelt zentren weiter geöffnet
teilweise in abgespeckter form die
impfungen sollen jetzt möglichst
niedrigschwellig diejenigen erreichen
die bislang gezögert haben hausärzte und
mobile im teams übernehmen nun viele
sagen das war höchste zeit
man darf dich vergessen eine impfung mit
dem cent kostet in etwa das zehnfache
von dem was das in der praxis kostet die
frage ist muss man solche
parallelstruktur und wirklich
aufrechterhalten und letztlich
finanzieren wir sie daher mit
krankenkassenbeiträgen oder jetzt mit
den steuern allein das impfzentrum in
hannover kostete 60 millionen euro ein
teil des inventars wird eingemottet um
soll bei bedarf schnell wieder
einsatzfähig sein ein kleiner teil wird
noch verkauft es ist das ende eines
kraftakts auch finanziell
in itzehoe sollte heute ein prozess
beginnen in dem es um tausendfachen mord
in der ns zeit geht doch dazu kam es
nicht die 96 jahre alte angeklagte war
morgen untergetaucht sie wurde später
zwar von der polizei gefasst das gericht
hatte die verhandlung da aber schon auf
mitte oktober verschoben die angeklagte
weise kriterien im ehemaligen
konzentrationslager stutthof ihr wird
beihilfe zum mord in 11.000 fällen
vorgeworfen sie hatte schon vor einiger
zeit in einem brief mitgeteilt dass sie
nicht zum prozess erscheinen werde
der frühere französische präsident
nicolas sarkozy ist zu einem jahr haft
verurteilt worden wegen illegaler
wahlkampffinanzierung
er darf die strafe zu hause absitzen
muss aber eine elektronische fußfessel
tragen der konservative politiker hatte
2012 fast doppelt so viel für seinen
wahlkampf ausgegeben wie erlaubt und
versucht die herkunft der gelder zu
verschleiern sarkozys anwalt will
berufung einlegen
und damit zurück nach deutschland hier
ringt die katholische kirche um
glaubwürdigkeit neues vertrauen und um
reformen der sogenannte synodale weg
soll dabei als gesprächsforum helfen in
frankfurt am main beginnt dabei jetzt
die nächste etappe auf der tagesordnung
zur lee bat machtverteilung und die
rolle der frau in der kirche linken
klinge über die details und die
anhaltende kritik am reformprozess
schon bevor es losgeht proteste der
frust vieler junger mitglieder des
reform dialog synodaler weg gerade über
den papst ist groß dass die
rücktrittsgesuche der bischöfe nicht
angenommen wurden ist natürlich
unglaublich schlechtes zeichen weil es
ganz deutlich zeigt dass wir uns nicht
darauf verlassen können das taten auch
konsequenzen haben und im saal will man
sich nun einigen erste entscheidungen
treffen noch nichts endgültiges aber die
bischöfe sollen macht abgeben laien
könnten sie mit auswählen frauen mehr
verantwortung in der katholischen kirche
bekommen so einige der vorschläge
konservative beugen diese entwicklung
skeptisch der regensburger bischof oder
holzer hat bereits klargemacht dass er
in vielen punkten nicht mitgehen wird
der vorsitzende der bischofskonferenz
bleibt aber optimistisch es gibt eine
große große mehrheit die ganz deutlich
hinter dem synodalen weg steht wir
werden es auch erleben dass wenn es dann
in die endabstimmung geht und texte
vorlegen das vielleicht nicht alle texte
die zwei drittel mehrheit der bischöfe
erhalten werden besonders das thema der
umverteilung der macht ist für viele
überfällig
wann soll denn was passieren wenn ich
jetzt nach all den beispielen die uns
vorführen so geht es nicht denn das was
wir erleben ist aus meiner sicht verrat
er an dem evangelium als wirklich gute
nachfolge ob es deutliche schritte
vorwärts geben wird ist offen und sehr
weitreichende reform werden in rom
schlechter erfolgsaussichten haben
jetzt in der sendung dramatische bilder
aus schleswig-holstein plötzlich und mit
großer wucht ist ein tornado gestern
abend über teile von kiel hinweggezogen
und hatte schwere schäden hinterlassen
an der uferpromenade wurden mehrere
menschen ins wasser geschleudert als sie
ihre boote sichern wollten sechs
personen wurden zum teil schwer verletzt
kaum zu glauben das ist kiel jetzt mal
den sport den er nun mit katja jemand
diese woche beginnen wir mit der fußball
champions league und heute mit glänzend
aufgelegten bayern den ganze fünfmal
landete der ball im gegnerischen tor von
dynamo kiew den doppelten auftakt zum
tor eigen machte ein alter bekannter
er hat es wieder getan robert
lewandowski auch im zweiten champions
league spiel mit einem doppelpack dem
elfmetertreffer zum 1 0 folgte nach
vorarbeit von thomas müller das 2 0 auch
die anderen bayern unersetzlich mit
großem torhunger der nach der pause vor
allem dadurch gestellt werden konnte
dass die gäste räume an boten einen
solchen sprintet es herrscht nabu und
rat brauchen zum 13 0 etwas glück im
spiel war dann beim tor von di rossi
zwar ungewollt aber das hat nicht
unbedingt unschön ins kurze eck vier zu
null zum guten schluss kein schuss
sondern dieser kopfball von choupo
moting 15 uhr ein perfekter champions
league abend für die bayern
wütend und fassungslos waren spieler und
trainer des vfl wolfsburg nach dem
champions league spiel gegen den fc
sevilla bis kurz vor schluss führte der
vfl mit 1 0 dann gab es eine ziemlich
umstrittene elfmeterentscheidung
ein standbild bringt die schiedsrichter
maßgeblich zu ihrem urteil obwohl in der
bewegung deutlich zu sehen ist dass der
wolfsburger gigawatt ideen bei spielt
und sein bein dann im durchschwingen nur
kurz ab stellt klar wenn ich ein
standbild zeige ich glaube da müssen wir
800 elfmeter pfeifen und standbilder sie
deswegen für mich gar kein elfmeter
killer woki bekommt auch noch die
gelb-rote karte seehas rakitic nutzt das
elfmetergeschenk zum 1 1-endstand
wolfsburg war durch renato steffen kurz
nach der pause in führung gegangen muss
sich am ende aber mit nur einem punkt
zufrieden geben und
alle tore und alle aus allen partien der
fußball champions league von gestern
finden sie wie immer zusammengefasst bei
uns online auf heute de und in der zdf-
heute- app und dann noch dass das
internationale olympische komitee hat
heute bekannt gegeben dass die
olympischen winterspiele im kommenden
februar ohne ausländische zuschauer
stattfinden werden tickets für die
wettbewerber an den unterschiedlichen
sportstätten werden demnach nur an in
china lebende fans ausgegeben grund ist
wie zuletzt auch bei den sommerspielen
die anhaltende corona pandemie
wieder mal besondere spiele vielen dank
katja zum schluss der sendung heute noch
der beweis dass man auch in badelatschen
und tennissocken zum echten helden
werden kann
alligator im vorgarten riesenproblem
aber dann hat eugene bau sie eine idee
und eine mülltonne
etwas hin und her
dann kann die umsiedlungsaktion in
florida beginnen unter großer
anteilnahme der nachbarn am ende
verlässt unseren helden zwar ein wenig
der mut aber alle sind glücklich und der
alligator
zurück in seinem sie
das wetter morgen meist trocken wann der
nächste regen kommt erfahren sie gleich
von westen telli
maria hat nachher das heute-journal wo
auch wir uns demnächst häufiger sehen
werden erlauben sie mir deshalb am ende
meiner letzten heute sendung um 19 uhr
eine kurze persönliche bemerkung das
waren sieben spannende herausfordernde
und meist schwierige nachrichten jahre
nichts ginge ohne das großartige team
hier hinter den kulissen immer
professionell seriös aber intern dabei
auch sehr witzig und sehr nett das
bleibt ihnen allen unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauern danke ich
für ihr vertrauen ihr enorm großes
interesse gerade auch während der
schweren pandemie zeiten das werde ich
nicht vergessen danke dass ich immer
wieder teil ihres abends sein darf jetzt
also ein paar stunden später im
heute-journal und deshalb wünsche ich
ihnen zum letzten mal an dieser stelle
einen angenehme haptik
[Musik]
beamte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter ja von westen her erreicht uns
bereits das nächste tief aber es kann
nicht so weit in den osten gelangen denn
hier haben wir es mit einem
umfangreichen hoch zu tun und das
blockiert den weg dieser regen hier und
der erreicht uns dann morgen abend und
das nächste tief fürs wochenende
bereitet sich schon auf dem atlantik vor
wir schauen in die nacht gibt es im
norden etwas regen ansonsten nach süden
ist es trocken und hier klart es
teilweise auf örtlichen gewässernähe
bildet sich da nebel dort dann
temperaturen bis 2 grad wird es kalt
teils mit bodenfrost und 12 grad an der
nordsee morgen dann im tagesverlauf
überwiegend dann trocken ja in der mitte
mehr wolken und zum abend dann der regen
der von nordwesten her reinzieht
ansonsten im süden und südosten viel
sonnenschein bei höchsten temperaturen
bis 22 grad am oberrhein und 16 grad zb
entlang der küsten die nächsten tage am
samstag gibt es neuen regen von westen
her temperaturen bis 23 grad und in der
nacht auf sonntag wird ungemütlich mit
viel wind und weiterem regen der sich
dann am sonntag fortsetzt und im süden
gibt es föhnsturm bis 26 grad ein
schöner abend